it's nice to meet you and it's been our
privilege to to help you have a
remarkable president
uh mr zielenski who's done an
outstanding job and
uh
we simply wish to keep supporting the
people of ukraine for as long as it
takes i want to begin vladimir by
saluting once again the
bravery of the people
of ukraine in defying the appalling
aggression that we have seen in the last
few weeks
the world has found new heroes
and
those heroes are the people of ukraine
when i was uh here just a few weeks ago
and we were in another room i think in
in your in your palace
uh
the
defense intelligence that we had
suggested that the
russians believed that ukraine could be
engulfed in a matter of days
and that kiev would fall
in hours
to their uh to their armies
and
how wrong
they were what putin has done in places
like bucca and in urban
his war crimes
have permanently polluted
his reputation
and the reputation
of his
of his government
and it's clear we we discuss this at
length it's clear that
what he's doing now he has suffered a
reverse
but
his retreat is tactical
and he's going to intensify the pressure
now
in donbass and
in the east
and together with our partners we are
going to ratchet up the economic
pressure
and we will continue to intensify a week
by week the sanctions
on
on russia
not just freezing assets in in banks and
uh and sanctioning oligarchs but moving
away from a use of russian hydrocarbons
and we will give
you the support that you need economic
support but also of course
the defensive military support in which
i'm proud to say that the uk
helped to
to lead the way but what this war is
certainly producing
is a clarity
about
the vision of a future
for ukraine
where together with
friends and partners
we
the uk and others supply the equipment
the technology the the know-how
the intelligence
so that ukraine will never
be invaded again
so the ukraine is so fortified and so
protected
that ukraine can never be bullied
again
never be blackmailed again never be
threatened in the same way
again